allora io faccio faccio l'imprenditore e
mi occupo di tecnologia nello specifico
di realtà virtuale realtà aumentata
ormai da vent'anni prima università poi
in un'azienda privata e ora con con la
mia azienda che cos'è la realtà virtuale
la realtà virtuale e un ramo della
dell'informatica che ha come finalità
quella di riprodurre fedelmente il mondo
che ci circonda
da un lato c'è il nostro mondo il mondo
reale dall'altro lato in ottica
dicotomica la sua rappresentazione
digitale che vuole essere sempre più
fedele al mondo che ci circonda
dicotomica perché si parla di realtà
immersiva io mi estraneo dal mondo reale
per immergermi nel mondo virtuale
la realtà aumentata si pone invece a
metà tra le due in una logica più falsi
che oscura le cerca di contaminare il
mondo fisico con degli elementi digitali
digitali e vuole in qualche modo
aiutarci ad interagire nel mondo reale
con delle informazioni ulteriori che
vengono fornite dalla computer grafica e
della rappresentazione 3d
un esempio è la capacità di poter
provare dei tagli di capelli di fronte
ad uno schermo quando inquadrato dalla
dalla videocamera vedo me stesso
inquadrato sullo schermo ma nel contempo
con un interazione naturale come se
fosse davanti ad uno specchio posso
vedere dei tagli di capelli priva ancora
di far tagliare i capelli e colorare i
miei capelli dal parrucchiere dal mio
hair stylist la storia che oggi racconto
e come mi piace impiegare le tecnologie
su cui lavoro da tanti anni per
risolvere i problemi della vita
quotidiana
parto quindi in realtà dalla mia
famiglia io una famiglia piuttosto
numerosa
numerosa per i tempi che viviamo oggi
ovviamente se guardiamo 50 anni fa non è
affatto una famiglia numerosa
ho una moglie e tre figli piccoli 6 5 e
4 anni due cani uno che con me da 11
anni col quale faccio le lunghissime
passeggiate 1 recentemente aggiunta la
famiglia quest'estate perché l'abbiamo
trovata in spiagge quattro gatti che
negli anni si sono aggiunti alla
famiglia qual è il problema che viviamo
tutti i giorni anche per la scelta che
abbiamo fatto come famiglia a quella di
seguire direttamente i figli la mancanza
totale di tempo la mia mattina la mia
giornata inizia molto presto alle 6
guardando passa al cane compro il pane
controllate con quel giornale torna a
casa porta i bambini a scuola vado in
ufficio spesso sono via per lavoro mia
moglie voleva prendere ci sono le feste
dei bambini lo sport le altre attività
serali si fa cena di nuovo al cane e ci
manca sostanzialmente il tempo per
occuparci uno di noi stessi ma molto
spesso anche per badare a cose più
elementare lo shopping la spesa comprare
i beni per la casa così come
l'elettronica di consumo
fortunatamente la tecnologia in questo
ci è venuto incontro negli anni
l'e commerce ci ha permesso già da
parecchi anni di comprare al
supermercato digitale o di comprare
l'elettronica
nell'ultimo anno abbiamo iniziato ad
acquistare
prodotti fashion abbiamo iniziato a
comprare abiti per noi per i nostri
bambini online
ahimé sembrava tutto facile ma in realtà
quello che succede
il prodotto spesso non mi piace arriva a
caso non mi piace lo provo non mi sta
bene o peggio ancora con i bambini ma
anche con noi è grande e piccolo tira
non mi sta bene non va bene quello che
doveva essere una semplificazione della
mia vita diventa di fatto una
complicazione devo rimpacchettati al
prodotto rispedirla al merchant e
riacquistare nuovamente il prodotto mi
sono chiesto è un problema che solo io
che non sono capace comprare prodotti
fashion on line oppure è un problema
condiviso da più persone
ho fatto qualche ricerca su google in
altri posti e in effetti il problema non
è soltanto mio
sostanzialmente il 30 per cento degli
acquisti nel mondo fashion on line
vengano restituiti al merchant
questo vuol dire che comprando il
prodotto
30 ogni 100 prodotti 30 vengono
restituiti che non dire per me un
problema perché devo andare all'ufficio
postale restituirle poi a ricomprare per
il merchant un serio problema economico
circa 5 miliardi di dollari all'anno
persi soltanto nella gestione della
logistica e soprattutto attendere circa
10 miliardi previste nei prossimi anni
questi sono dati di forza del sud
ma anche
una grossa inefficienza qual è quello
quello su cui stanno varando in questo
momento una possibile soluzione
demandare l'acquisto dei prodotti
fashion ad un mio clone digitale di
avere in tasca nel mio cellulare online
ovunque io sia un ulteriore
rappresentazione di me stesso la
rappresentazione che deve essere
ovviamente fedele deve essere semplice
nella sua creazione possiamo passare la
prossima slide perché io non voglio
perdere tempo quindi devo
immediatamente avere la creazione del me
stesso digitale e il lavoro che stiamo
facendo e di permettergli di costruire
il tuo avatar con sei passi molto
semplici in genere le linee ha l'età
dovete fare un click per cortesia
il genere le mie l'età è un paio di
misure antroposofo antropomorfiche del
proprio corpo altezza lunghezza delle
braccia e qualcos'altro
l'avatar da solo si autogenera ed a quel
punto mi rappresenta nell'istante in cui
l'ho creato ovviamente l'avatar può
essere passo dopo passo mese dopo mese
anno dopo anno aggiornato per
permettermi di fare gli acquisti della
taglia giusta se ingrasso dimagrisco il
pasto successivo scelgo il prodotto
online e lo trovo posso vedere il tipo
di materiale e l'abito un problema che
abbiamo
affrontato che su cui in realtà stiamo
lavorando parecchio e la
rappresentazione di me a me capita molto
spesso quando mi vedo allo specchio mi
piaccio quando mi vedo in una fotografia
o in un filmato non mi riconosco così
bene probabilmente perché l'immagine
percepita di me stesso che ho nel mio
inconscio e nettamente superiore a
quello che sono effettivamente
il lavoro che stiamo cercando di fare è
di utilizzare le tecnologie che noi
effettivamente di cui disponiamo per
dare dalla presentazione di the che non
ti mette in difficoltà e che ti permetta
con serenità di fare la condivisione del
tuo avatar durante il tra gli on con i
tuoi amici senza che tu possa essere
imbarazzato ma nel contempo l'avatar è
un mio alter ego digitale mi permette di
fare regali i miei amici se mia moglie
vuole che le regali un top mi presta il
suo avatar digitale perché io possa
scegliere lo stile il colore dell'abito
che lei vuole indossare
l'unica cosa che possa garantirle e che
la taglia sia quella corretta quello che
non possa garantire che le piace mio
regalo ovviamente ma quantomeno abbia
risolto un problema ne sta bene le sta
bene per me e la taglia è quella giusta
come arriviamo a rappresentare l'abito
direttamente sull'avatar applicando
quella che è però quella realtà virtuale
ovvero
riproducendo sinteticamente con
la computer science quello che
viene fatto effettivamente nella realtà
chi produce vestiti fa il proprio design
con dei cag bidimensionali disegna ogni
singolo pezzo della stoffa in 2d che
viene poi tagliato con le macchine a
controllo numerico e cocito con delle
macchine da cucire a volte in maniera
industriale a volte in maniera
sartoriale artigianale
noi stiamo riproducendo quello partiamo
da quello che il brand del settore
fashion anno
e con delle macchine da cucire
digitali cuciamo questi pezzi di stoffa
che a quel momento sono intangibili e
facciamo il rating sul corpo digitale
il risultato finale è un drive
fisicamente corretto come sappiamo
quando effettivamente il vestito è
piccolo e grande soprattutto i difetti
che si vengono a formare sul proprio
corpo
è solo teoria no è un qualcosa si stia
lavorando che probabilmente chiunque di
voi potrà utilizzare a partire dai
prossimi
12 mesi
e volendo ci si potrà anche inventare
qualche sfilata virtuale di voi come
della vostra moglie ovviamente
non pensiamo di cambiare il mondo con
queste tecnologie ma di rendere nel
nostro piccolo la vita un pochettino più
semplice le cose più smooth per chi è
purtroppo per fortuna comunque parecchio
impegnato grazie